Découvrez maintenant l'histoire de Jean.
Jean a vécu une histoire incroyable.
Celle d'un crime passionnel.
Tout de suite, un reportage de Nathan Henneton.
C'est dans cette petite cuisine des Yvelines
que Jean Malour est entré le 24 janvier 2004.
Jean rentre dans sa cuisine, il a faim, c'est l'heure du goûter, c'est sûr.
Il ouvre son placard.
Il voit le paquet de biscuits.
Et là...
Un biscuit tombe.
Absolument.
Jean Malour avait selon ses mots une petite fringale.
Mais tout ne s'est pas passé comme prévu.
Comment un de ces biscuits a-t-il pu s'échapper du paquet ?
Peut-être que la partie en plastique à l'intérieur du paquet était à l'envers.
Qu'en est-il par exemple de cette usine ?
Parce qu'il y a un flou médiatique.
Nous nous sommes rendus dans l'usine qui produit ces fameux biscuits fourrés au chocolat
pour tenter d'y voir plus clair.
Vous vous cassez Monsieur, vous dégagez !
J'ai des questions à vous poser sur le biscuit.
Vous n'avez pas le droit de savoir ça, c'est classifié,
vous dégagez !
Je n'étais pas présent ce jour-là,
donc forcément je n'ai pas bien vu.
J'habite dans un autre pays,
je ne comprends pas ce que vous dites...
Oui Monsieur, est-ce que vous pouvez répondre clairement à ma question :
Le paquet était-il retourné, oui ou non ?
Notre interlocuteur reste muet.
La barquette était-elle bien à l'envers ?
Impossible d'en savoir plus.
Vous savez, ce genre d'accident peut arriver à vous et moi.
Jean Malour est quelqu'un de normal.
Nos experts scientifiques ont tenté de recréer les circonstances du drame.
Mais leurs analyses n'ont rien donné de concluant.
Biscuit.
Alors, qu'est-il réellement arrivé à ce biscuit ?
La question reste grande ouverte.
Cet évènement sans précédent a tant marqué les esprits
Qu'il a même inspiré un long métrage
dont voici les premières images exclusives.
La rencontre avec Jean Malour a été déterminante pour moi.
Et quand il m'a raconté son histoire
et surtout comment il s'en est sorti...
Combien d'hommes en sont capables ?
Après plusieurs appels téléphoniques
et l'aide précieuse de nos témoins,
nous avons enfin pu contacter l'homme au coeur de cette affaire :
Jean Malour.
Il s'est livré à nos caméras pour nous raconter son histoire,
sa confession est poignante :
Bah, je l'ai ramassé et...
je l'ai mangé.
Enfin, j'ai...
j'ai soufflé dessus, et...
et je l'ai mangé, quoi.
Il avait le même goût.
Un reportage...
édifiant.
On a tout vu là du reportage ?
D'accord... ouais.